now I'll brought to this question is
intimidating many questions are designed
to be intimidating just when you look at
them you get sort of scared but I don't
it will start okay
however if you can see through through
the structure problem then all the
intimidating stuff just kind of washes
away so you can't don't put the reverted
on you help me look at this and think
what kind of factorization tools do you
already have access to you know you
actually can do this - but you said
unfortunate about what kind of
foundations will do have access to which
could make let you help me get a start
on love it's barely solvent but at least
do something up to it and if he sends on
this yeah okay difference of squares so
maybe just underneath it you want to
write down difference of squares the
difference of squares is totally the
expanded form looks like difference of
squares comes from the name right so
you're going to have squares such as
this and what is different apply you're
subtracting now you have to give this
video to them okay so that's what you
have expended what is the factorization
we tend to write the a minus B first
just because usually gave us the end up
being a smaller number success is
anything but it doesn't matter
application is commutative so I could
put it with any other I like this is the
factorization that will be useful to me
in a minute
however I'm a little perplexed that
that's the first place you go because
later I read it I don't see any a
squared minus B squared
even the question so where is it hiding
everyone is to just sort of you take out
16
so up in this numerator here the first
clue you've got is this is the only
difference in the entire question okay
all of these things are son's not
differences so this is a good place to
go
yeah 832 Donnell look like it's a square
I told you factorize and tease it out a
little bit okay so I'm going to write
science of admitting I just take it back
I'm just going to go to the right you
don't you don't need these factors of
because it will do you've got it yes
good I'm going to pull out as we
suggested a factor of whatever the curve
16 okay so 8 and 32 is a to the power of
16 squared do you agree with that in
this experience of ethically just icky
index laws when you've got numbers with
the same base while you do to their
powers when they multiply they as this
is 16 plus 16 16 times 2 when you have
power and power okay so there's that guy
and over here I have the baby 16 are you
happy with that does that make sense
so what I've got now is a rewritten the
numerator in a more factorized form
because it reveals more of the structure
that's useful to be namely and even
though it doesn't look like it is
actually a difference of squares okay I
better finish off writing the rest of
this thing Hey
okay so now if you compare what we've
just written to this you can see I can
transpose this numerator into this form
and then it's factorize and I can see
some structure right what's it going to
look like when it's saturated at the top
suggestions 15 good there's is the stop
and now I can move on to the next step
right and immediately you can see
without even writing the rest of the
question oh now there is a way that I
can access this right I can start to
work with common factors in a PR in the
first denominator there is what we
identify even though one of obvious from
the get-go okay
there are common factors here that can
be manipulated okay
so I like to pause for a moment there
and now that was sort of a lot at least
access to the question oh I can simplify
this in some way right honestly if you
can sort of dig your way into the
question remembering that this is the
one other clue that you've been given
and when trying to find a value for this
whole thing why don't you spend a few
minutes to see half idea if you never
call you a lot okay so I know a lot of
you haven't quite got there that's fine
I reckon at this point you either have
it or you're closed off you're like oh I
can see we're just going to go or
alternatively you're hitting your head
against a brick wall not making any
progress so let me give you a here you
can see what you factorize this out
right you get this combination you
identify the comebacker so off it goes
we can cancel it that's kind of nice and
you get left with this guy well the same
trick that is used before to identify
that these are squares even necessarily
look like it helps you here as well okay
how do you factorize agency
t-minus 10 to 16 another step what do
you do it's a and this again but instead
of and B it's going to be a to the 8 so
this thing here is the difference of
squares all over again which again had
sort of unlocked another sort of um
another level of casting that you can do
once you get through the bottoms once
you get to the bottom after you
cancelled as far as you can go what do
you end up with you a bracelet - piece
one you end up with that right and then
you've got this twelve bait hanging off
on the end oh gee is that correct
okay now come back to the original
question the original question says
evaluate which in case you can't quite
remember because you've been using this
work for so long maybe you haven't
thought about what mean evaluate means
find the value of this thing we should
try to clue into hey you should be able
to get rid of all of the algebra here
and just get our value and number at the
end okay so to have a look at this one
last time we can actually use the banjo
I mentioned in this mobile form so this
is a minus B a plus B and at last that
piece of the information you were told
of the beginning which is kind of just
hanging around there like what on earth
is that guy doing you can use him down
right so in here I can substitute you
and this becomes six outside of a minus
B you're great like I just used the
substitution
okay now I loved you actually get to use
this guy it is expanding your
factorizing so no one because six times
six times a month
oh it's sex a month since people speak
which leads to sex a person to feel into
the piece to set up broken clean
pristine okay so this is our second last
line you can see I've had to expand
because then I can refactor eyes right
it allows me quite like ten memory but
right mr. Quan is six no six so there is
our value as promised
so what are we learning to you right
when you look at something that is
disastrous and terrible if you can
factorize the reason why cancelling
emerges is because you understand the
structure of what is going on so
therefore you can get rid of the
extraneous stuff the stuff that actually
is all just flop and turns out there's a
lot of fluff code this is just a fancy
way of writing faces okay alright so
what likely I'm going to show you and I
those of you who have enjoyed the
problems review will see that a problem
just like this is what you'll encounter
I think in problems 3 & 4
I believe it's up the avantika the last
thing I wanna show you is so far
simplified looks like taking something
that looks huge and condensing it down
into something that looks slow and to be
fair that's usually what it is however
not always the case
think back to this which if these is
shorter to write a screen where this
credit is objectively we go to write the
direct you terms right it looks like you
taking a step backwards to my fears
excuse me
however a minus B a plus B is more
useful in on water projects because you
see structure so to illustrate that on
what should have a look at this okay
this guy over here looks like it's about
as simple as it
right you can't use different squares on
it right so what are you going to do
with this I'm going to give you the
comments to play first the play step is
really important play I've already
rubbed it off play is what helps you
look at numbers and realize there is a
pattern to these factors and there's a
reason why my number has a lot of number
of factors and no one else is not I need
you to play with this for a moment
however would it see what you can do you
try to factorize okay it's simple yes
but I don't see any structure so if you
can factorize see what you can do it how
to play and see what emerges what do you
do